- So you're very open about
everything in the documentary,
about your health, about
the highs and lows,
it's not like some depressing,
it's a lot of things
all the emotions,
but I thought that it was really
cool that you were so open
about, I mean, having lupus
about bipolar disorder,
about going to speak, what was that like
speaking at the hospital?
- That was amazing.
I went to the McLean Hospital
and it's one of the
best hospitals for all,
I mean, they are, they're
kind of covering everything
in the mental health space.
And so I was able to say
my diagnosis out loud
for the first time.
And it just,
- Yeah.
- it gave me such strength and it really,
it wasn't easy and I
think that's why I wanted
the documentary to feel really personal.
But I'm kind of scared, like
a lot of people are gonna see
this whole other side of me and
I'm like, hope they like it.
- I think it's refreshing.
I think it's nice 'cause
it's such a filtered world.
Like and we're different generations
so it's just like, it's I feel
like your age and younger,
like, it's just such a different world
where everybody filters everything online
and and that's not life.
That's not real life.
Like everybody has things,
right?
- Yes.
- And I just thought it was very powerful
like to not know what
was happening with you,
but you knew something was wrong.
You sought out help and you got it.
And that's gonna help so
many people that watch this.
I hope so.
- Yes.
Whether it's depression or
whatever, anxiety, like whatever.
It's like it really does.
You watch it and you go, okay
wait, I do vibe with that.
Like, that's similar to me.
So it's, it's gonna, I think,
awaken a lot of people.
- I hope so 'cause I'm really nervous.